[music]
Lynn Loo:
Plastic electronics are electronic devices in which the active components are made out
of carbon-based materials, so these are plastics, polymers or small molecules. The reason you
Lynn Loo:
want to make plastic electronics is because you want to make use of the attributes of
these plastic materials. These include their mechanical flexibility, they're lightweight,
Lynn Loo:
they can be produced with tunable properties, and this is something you can't easily do
with inorganic materials. My name is Yueh-Lin Loo, and I work in the field of plastic electronics.
Lynn Loo:
In the field of plastic electronics, it all starts with chemistry. We need to make or
synthesize new materials that are conductive or semi-conductive, so they have the electrical
Lynn Loo:
properties that we would like, so that when we incorporate them into electronic devices,
they're active. In our group, some of the researchers make new materials, some of the
Lynn Loo:
researchers characterize the structures of these materials, and some of them incorporate
these materials to understand their potential in applications like transistors and solar cells
Lynn Loo:
Polyaniline is a conducting polymer that changes color. Here, this color change
is triggered by applying a voltage to the sample. The potential applications for polyaniline,
Lynn Loo:
in addition to being electrodes, is that we can use it as electrochromic displays, as
well as sensors that change color when it's exposed to a specific chemical or reagent.
Lynn Loo:
We use a process called spin coating to make thin layers of these compounds. The layers
end up to be about a hundred nanometers thick. That's about a thousand times thinner than my hair.
Lynn Loo:
Here, we examine the films we make under the microscope to see how the crystals grew during
spin coating. We try to control the size of the crystals in the film.
Lynn Loo:
The bigger the crystals, the better the devices will turn out.
To make the devices, we have to make electrical contact to the film by evaporating gold.
Lynn Loo:
Gold is evaporated through a mask. The pattern of the mask determines where gold is coated.
After the placement of the mask, we put the sample in the gold evaporator.
Lynn Loo:
Alternatively, we can evaporate gold electrodes on a clear silicone rubber stamp, and laminate the rubber
stamp onto the polymer film to make our devices.
Lynn Loo:
The structure of the devices depends on their function. In my opinion, their beauty derives
from their functionality. Compared to inorganics like silicon, plastics have unique attributes.
Lynn Loo:
These include their lightweightness, their mechanical flexibility, their potential low
cost, and their tunability in terms of their properties. So, to incorporate all these attributes
Lynn Loo:
into electronic devices would be really nice.
The field's really exciting because it's a young field, and it's growing, and it's directly
Lynn Loo:
tied to applications that can have direct implications on the quality of our lives.
Imagine electronic wallpaper that changes patterns from green stripes to pink polka
Lynn Loo:
dots at a click of a switch. Imagine tinted windows that can also generate power during
the day. Imagine disposable sensors that would change color if the water source is contaminated.
Lynn Loo:
Or yet, think of smart plastic patches that can monitor your health and deliver medication
when you're sick. The possibilities are endless.
[music]